for more on the administration's foreign
policy we turn to CBS News senior
security contributor and former deputy
director of the CIA Michael Morell so
North Korea says they are ready to go to
war they say that they hope for the best
but prepare for the worst you say they
have the capacity to strike the United
States right now with ICBMs do you see
North Korea potentially launching a
preemptive strike the reason that Kim
jong-un has nuclear weapons wants the
ability to deliver them to the
continental United States is because he
believes that we want to get rid of him
he believes we want to reunite the
peninsula on South Korea's terms and he
sees nuclear weapons as the ultimate
deterrent against that he also knows
that if he ever uses them that we will
respond with massive force annihilate
him so so my view is that he will only
ever use them in a in a last last ditch
effort to survive so I don't think we
need to worry about the bluster that we
see from him in the last 24 hours is he
worried about the bluster that he hears
and he sees from the president yeah yes
exactly because it feeds his paranoia
about the United States it feeds his
view that we are out to get him
so so he started this crisis with a
series of provocations after the
president came to office that was
designed for a specific diplomatic
purpose of getting us to the negotiating
table so we'll give him something for
his bad behavior that's what the Clinton
administration's did that's what the
Bush administration did the Obama
administration stopped that they ignored
him ignored him essentially he wants to
get back to the Clinton and Bush years
where he does something bad we come
running to the negotiating table and we
give him something right we we buy
something from him he wants to get back
to that that's why he started this
crisis were feeding the crisis with our
bluster and by sending aircraft carriers
into the area were feeding that the best
thing we could do is as you said ignore
him maybe tighten sanctions a little bit
every time he does something bad but
basically we need to deter him from ever
using or so
a nuclear weapon and we need to build
our defenses our missile defense in the
region so that we can deal with him in
the launch phase and our missile defense
in the United States so we can deal with
him in the in the terminal phase of a
missile launch that's how we have to
deal with North Korea you said something
interesting he believes that we want to
get rid of him yes we know that he is a
brutal dictator is that stated policy of
the United States do we want to get rid
of Jang we don't don't write we don't
I mean wanted unify the or do whatever
we do we don't we don't if I the
peninsula no the only thing we care
about is his behavior that's it his
behavior stop your bad behavior and and
you can do whatever I want do what you
want to internally stop your bad
behavior right he does not believe that
interesting all right so let's talk
about China their role in North Korea
this past week the president met with Xi
Jinping he came away saying he learned a
lot apparently the president of China or
the Chinese Communist Party leader
explained him a little bit about Korean
history and Chinese history do you think
they're going to be able to help in this
situation so there's two issues China is
key to putting pressure on North Korea
80% of North Korea's trade is with China
so sanctions don't really matter unless
China plays right so there's two issues
with China their willingness to squeeze
North Korea and then their ability the
willingness is questionable why because
they fear an unstable North Korea more
than they fear an unstable nuclear-armed
North Korea more than they fear a
nuclear-armed North Korea they don't
want to bring about instability in North
Korea that would result in loose nuclear
weapons no control over those nuclear
weapons and refugees flowing into China
so they have never been willing to
squeeze North Korea really hard because
they're afraid of the instability that's
the willingness question then you have
the ability question there's an
assumption on when people talk about
this that if China only did squeeze them
hard North Korean behavior would change
I questioned that assumption I don't
think North Korean behavior would change
even if China squeezed them so I don't
think China is the answer
China's not the answer the answer is so
it's what I said right this guy's not
going to give up these weapons because
he believes he needs them to survive
he's never going to want to have a deal
with the United States because he needs
the United States as an enemy because he
asked his people for significant
sacrifices to deal with the enemy the
United States so there is no deal with
the United States in his mind so the
only way to deal with this guy is to
deter him just the way we used to deter
the Soviet Union from using nuclear
weapons we need to deter him we need to
make it clear to him that if he ever
uses nuclear weapons he will be
annihilated right we need we need to
make that perfectly clear to him and
then we need to strengthen our defenses
that's the way you deal with this guy
and then don't react right to everything
that he does so do we not if he does
test a nuclear weapon this weekend what
should be our response um I would I
would not respond militarily once you
want to bring about war on the peninsula
right I was that will be the result
exactly I would bring about I would
tighten sanctions right and I would ask
China to tighten sanctions but you don't
want to you don't want to tighten
sanctions so much that you bring about
that instability that we all fear Wow it
is a conundrum and and I do know that
the president President Obama told the
incoming administration there's a lot of
things that you're going to have to deal
with this is the single biggest issue of
your presence and a big and President
Obama said that for two reasons one is
because he knew what capabilities they
had and he knew those capabilities were
increasing in sophistication and he also
knew that Kim jong-un was going to test
President Trump to try to get him back
to the negotiating table that's why he
told President Trump that this was the
biggest issue Michael Morell thank you
so much great to be with you yeah thank
you